c'est rien qu'une histoire de plus rien
une histoire vécue
on s'est dit vous et puis tu me tues
institué
en cette chambre sens la vue l'impasse
de la vertu
c'est rien que l'histoire du cuir
que l'histoire vécue
c'est bien qu'une histoire de curry
l'histoire vécue
écrit dans le noir des mots crus de
trois choses on a cru
des mots doux qu'on n'aurait pas tout un
film qu'on n'a pas vu
c'est rien qu'une histoire de coeur
qu'une histoire de cul
sourire
c'est le seul
souvenir d'abord
ah non ap
soupire d'amour
parle-t-il de la paix
congre avenauds disco sur les corses
d'échelle
e
le
c'est rien qu'une histoire de cul
une histoire vécue
une chanson qui aiment les murs qu'on
siffle et puis
trois petites notes un air connu baisser
un peu
oh
c'est rien qu'une histoire de kurt
kuehn histoire vécue
soupir
qu'on solutionne
sous les eaux
un an à peine ou
sur l'amour
malte il est bien là
programme du disco sur les causes du
challenge
soupir de monde
ceux du chan
s'ouvrir 2
un nom un peu
sous peine de mort
altitude de la plaine
congre à flot du sco
sur les corses des chameaux